you know what it is like fight is like
aids it's that thing that's everywhere
on TV and then it goes away and you're
like I forgot about I don't even think
about it anymore and then something
comes on TV to remind you about it you
know like oh that's right that's that's
still around that's not over with now I
got to think about that that is tight so
I just randomly flipped on the B movie
awards and it was just like
well don't need to watch that anymore so
then I go on YouTube and I'm like
alright I'm gonna find solace in the
videos online and what what is - oh my
god a new trailer to the new one there's
no escaping it so now I'm gonna talk
about the trailer so the trailer starts
out these people are getting these
letters and you don't know what the
letters are but about this time right
here when Wolfe freaks out and goes for
a run you realize that their wedding
invitations which is really pathetic for
that guy cuz this is the third move he's
been to movies this is the third word he
hasn't gotten it through his head she
doesn't want him she doesn't want you to
just get over it looked pathetic in like
the last two movies
yeah man cut your losses go after C or
something
look at this chick smug look ha ha
fellas getting married
and what's up with this trailer music
it's way too epic for a wedding
Figment removed due to copyright
infringement are you serious with this I
mean this trailer music would work if
like magneto was pulling a submarine out
of the water segment removed due to
copyright infringement
well Thor was out there just kicking
butt a wedding that's just unnecessary
that's overkill just be realistic about
it and play Pachelbel's Canon in D major
due to copyright infringement I say play
that because that's what plays at every
single wedding ever
you can probably bet the chips that
they're actually gonna play Pachelbel's
Canon in D major in the Twilight wedding
saying great song I love the song just
and then we see the scene like the only
scene I've ever heard about in the books
they didn't break the bad signature move
due to copyright infringement all right
I'm gonna be realistic to all the 13
year-olds out there breaking the bed on
your first time will not happen and if
that scene is three minutes long that's
2 minutes 30 seconds longer than it
probably should be and then at the end
of the trailer Oh oh my gosh she's
pregnant that happens when you have sex
that's weird oh there's another one
another baby's gonna have to chew out of
her uterus that's another thing I've
heard about baby chews through her
uterus or something like that
I got nothing I got nothing and to all
the parts who apparently are watching
this video here it is you hate to just
be honest with yourself and here's why
cuz you watched me a guy you don't even
know rip on tight for an entire video
which means you wanted to watch me do
that which means you hate to now you
should subscribe cuz all the cool kids
are doing it so there it is guys the new
movie ah Sh part why not it divides
bright we got a part to you to put up
with but think of it this way as long as
there is a infecting movie theaters near
you
there'll be me on YouTube to talk about
it creating balance in the world what
I'm all about and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
you